so yesterday we learned about this
incredible situation in which my pillow
founder mike lindell also known as mike
pillow or just pillow we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines that guy yeah
he had his phone seized by the fbi while
at a hardy's drive-through
we now have the search warrant
that was presented to pillow
and the search warrant exposes that this
guy is potentially in extremely serious
trouble
newsweek has it in an article called
read fbi's mike lindell search warrant
items to be seized and if you scroll
down the article
you get to a section which is the list
of everything to be seized check this
out so of course it says the physical
cellular telephone assigned to pillow
which they got
all records and information on the
lindell cell phone that constitute
fruits evidence or instrumentalities of
violations of identity theft
intentional damage to a protected
computer
conspiracy to cuff link identity theft
and on and on and on and it lists a
number of different people but that is
where it really gets very interesting
when you look at the specifics
so it's a seizure of records and
information relating to damage to
dominion voting systems
there may be crimes here in having
damaged voting machines the guy saying
he's investigating the voting machines
may have damaged voting machines records
and information relating to bios on a
dominion voting system machine
records and information relating to the
attachment of any peripheral to a
dominion voting system machine
records and information relating to any
optical disk drive so a lot of dominion
voting machine stuff okay
you then go further
and you start to see all records and
information
relating to conan james hayes conan
james hayes use
of another person's name
photograph credentials or identifying
information or documents who is conan
james hayes
this is uh one of these guys
who um has spearheaded election
disinformation was involved in the
arizona so-called audit and seems to be
wrapped up in the pillow stuff with the
machines
and it all stinks to high heaven and
there's possible identity theft here as
well
another really interesting item is item
m
evidence
of who used owned or controlled the
lindell cell phone
at the time things described in the
warrant were created
edited
or deleted so this now
it's very clear that the fbi is also
concerned with destruction of evidence
potentially here
uh evidence of software that would allow
others to control the lindell cell phone
evidence of the attachment to the
lindell cell phone of other storage
devices
and on and on and on this is
extraordinarily detailed and i know many
people will say
anytime the fbi seizes a phone
they have a whole bunch of these
different things there fair
but these are very specific provisions
and items
elements for lack of a better term
that relate to
what mike pillow was up to
and so there's clearly a concern about
deleted evidence the subpoena includes
that and just think
if trump
and pillow had just stuck with you know
their respective bailiwicks
which for trump was
you know i don't know real estate stuff
and for pillow was selling pillows
they would both probably be
better off right now certainly legally
and the united states of america would
be dramatically better off we will see
what happens next and by the way this
seizure has completely triggered mike
pillow uh but we'll talk about that more
on tomorrow's program guys in trouble
though guys it seems to be in serious
trouble the summer is over busy season
is back in full force who has time to
meal prep and cook and clean up every
single day i don't and that's why i turn
to splendid spoon our sponsor splendid
spoon delivers delicious ready-to-eat
plant-based meals right to my door i'm
not vegan but i like increasing my plant
intake and splendid spoon is the perfect
way to do it so many different reasons
why an increasingly plant-based diet is
a great thing you can choose from over
50 meals from breakfast smoothies and
lunch bowls to noodle dinners and light
soups so much variety vegetables legumes
healthy fats whole grains spices from
all over the world
one of my
absolute favorites are the green
smoothies so much great stuff in them
get started today and get a hundred and
twenty dollars off your first three
boxes at splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below